-Welcome back to the show.
-Thank you.
-It's...
-[ Chuckles ] Amazing.
It's wonderful to be here.
-It means so much
to have an actor
come on the show
that can talk
about their project.
-It's great --
-It's a big deal for us.
You're our first --
-Thank you. Thank you, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you so much.
-It's really good to be here.
I'm really grateful to you.
-I want to talk about "Loki,"
and congrats on that Season 2.
But I also want to talk about --
you did this thing.
I think you do it annually.
It's an England vs. the World
soccer match.
-Soccer Aid. Yes.
-Yes.
-It's called Soccer Aid
for UNICEF.
And it's basically
this extraordinary event
at a big soccer stadium
in England.
It was Old Trafford,
where Manchester United play
this summer in June.
And you -- basically former pros
and keen amateurs like myself.
-Yeah, I mean,
you're really good.
-No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Come on, Jimmy.
I am -- I'm a --
I said "keen amateur," like...
-I mean, no, but, no, no, no --
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, I'm playing up
against people
like Paul Scholes
and Francesco Totti...
-Not them, yeah.
-...you know, Roberto Carlos.
Yeah. So...
-Yeah.
Not counting them out.
-You're the best.
-[ Chuckles ]
-I mean, yeah.
-Yeah, well, you know.
-If you don't mention the other
players, you're number one.
-Exactly. Yeah.
-Yeah.
-Forget about Paul Scholes.
Anyway, so --
so it was this summer,
and it's England versus
the rest of the world.
And we raise loads of money
for children.
-Good for you.
-Yeah. It was -- It was fun.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And it was fun.
I played --
I played for England,
not for the rest of the world.
[ Light laughter ]
And...
-Did you win?
-We didn't, sadly.
-Yeah, okay. The world won.
-The world won.
-Okay. The world won.
-But that's good for the world.
-We're rooting for the world.
-We're rooting for the world,
always.
-Absolutely, yes.
-But it was hilarious.
I mean, in training we had --
we -- there was a --
there was a moment where,
like -- 'cause I --
as I say, I'm keen,
maybe not entirely skillful,
but I put in a bit
of a sort of hard challenge
on my opposite number.
And she was like, "Oh, ref,
did you see that challenge?"
And the ref was like,
"He's Loki.
He's using his magical powers.
What can I do?"
-Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, you can use that.
But I saw you running
with Usain Bolt.
-Well, so, this is a kickoff.
I didn't -- I was playing right,
on the right wing,
defensive midfielder.
And I look up to see
who I'm man-marking,
and it's the fastest man alive.
[ Laughter ]
-That's like -- That's the best.
-It's like, "Okay, good luck."
-That's the best challenge
in the world.
-"Good luck." Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-You're like -- Yeah.
-Absolutely amazing.
-Yeah.
-I mean -- he's -- when you --
when you hear --
you see
the legs coming towards you,
it's like an express train.
-No. Yeah.
-Yeah.
-He's the fastest.
Yeah. Here's you.
I think you're kind of
holding your own there.
-He's floating, you notice.
He's --
-Yeah.
-He's, like,
still walking on water.
-Yeah.
-Let me see.
There's one of you --
Here's what I wanted to show.
You should frame this.
-[ Chuckling ] Okay.
-This is you running alongside
Usain Bolt.
Look at this.
-Look at this guy.
-Not bad.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Not bad. Respect!
-Yeah. I mean...
-The form. The form. The form.
-Yeah, I like to think --
I don't know if it's the angle,
but in this photograph,
I'm ahead of him.
-Yeah, that's exactly right.
Thank you. That's --
That's all that matters.
Frame this.
-But the determination,
honestly --
and I said to him afterwards --
-He's the best.
-He's the best. Like,
he's a real football fan --
soccer fan -- sorry --
I should say.
-No, of course.
-And I love running.
And it's a big part of my life.
And he's just an icon for me.
I mean, he's like
an international sports icon.
-Yeah.
-And to go against him
was just like such a thrill
and privilege.
-No, but he's running next to
you, going like, "That's Loki!"
[ Laughter ]
-He had a few laughs.
You know, he -- I think
I gave him a few problems,
'cause, obviously,
he's unbelievably quick.
-Yeah.
-And so people just want
to swing the ball over to him,
and he'll put it
in the back of the net.
But -- But I was --
I was -- I stuck to him.
You know, I held my own.
-You did a great job.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I want to talk about --
Let's talk about "Loki"
while we -- we can do it now.
-We're here. We're here, yeah.
-We're allowed to talk about it.
-Season 2 was great!
-Thank you. Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It was great!
-Thank you so much.
-And we couldn't discuss
Season 2,
but now we can discuss it.
The season finale is --
you can get the whole Season 2
on Disney+ right now.
I don't want to spoil it.
No spoilers.
-Yeah.
-If you're watching,
we will not spoil it.
But what can we say --
what can we say
about the finale?
-I mean, if you haven't seen it,
no, I will not spoil it for you.
But I will say this -- it --
it all comes full circle.
[ Audience oohs ]
And...
-Yeah. That's a great --
Well, you know how to --
He knows how to do it. Yeah.
He knows how to do it.
-Yeah. I mean,
it is a kind of -- it's --
it's the conclusion to Season 2.
It's also a conclusion
to seasons 1 and 2.
It's also the conclusion to --
to 6 films and 12 episodes
and 14 years of my life.
It's -- And so -- And in --
I think, in the finale --
-Has it been 14 years?
-14 years.
I was 29 when I was cast.
I'm 42 now.
-Wow, bud.
-It's been a journey.
-Good for you.
Congratulations.
-Thank you. But -- But --
-You did a great job.
-Thank you.
-You've done a great job.
-But in the -- in the finale,
I do think, in the finale,
there are echoes and resonances
of every version of Loki
that I've played.
And I think,
without spoiling it,
I think it all -- the episode is
called "Glorious Purpose."
-Oh, that's your line.
-And if you remember,
in the first "Avengers" film,
Loki comes down to Earth,
looks straight at Sam Jackson
as Nick Fury,
and I say, "I'm Loki of Asgard.
I'm burdened with
glorious purpose."
And he's arrogant,
and he's hubristic,
and he's entitled,
and he's puffed up,
and he's going to take
over the world.
And then, you know,
it doesn't go so well for him.
We've all seen "Infinity War."
[ Laughter ]
Face-to-face with Thanos.
-Yes.
-Not so glorious.
-Yeah.
-At the beginning of Season 1,
Mobius, played by Owen Wilson --
the best ever.
-He's so good in this.
-So great.
-He's great, and he's also
really funny in this, too.
-He's hilarious.
-Yeah.
-But he basically shows Loki
that the glorious purpose
was a fallacy.
And he gets kind of
a second chance.
And that, I think, was the most
exciting thing about this show
was seeing Loki try to rethink
and rediscover
that sense of purpose,
which we can all relate to.
I think, you know, we all wonder
if we're in charge
of our own story.
-Yeah.
-You know, can we --
can a leopard change his spots?
Do we have any free will?
And in exercising
your free will,
you make choices
in your own life.
You get a -- I don't know --
you get a black coffee
or a latte or a cappuccino.
That's a choice.
I mean, it's a small choice.
-It's all choices.
-But, yeah, every -- every --
every choice you make adds up
to the picture of your life.
And do those choices
inform your purpose?
And I think all of us as people
want happy lives,
but we also want lives
with a purpose.
And that's really what the show
is talking about.
-Yeah. I-I-I -- It's very good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's a way -- a great way to
describe it without spoiling it.
-In the end,
it comes back to, like,
meaning and identity
and family,
which is really what "Loki"
has always been about.
It's always been about
purpose and family.
-There's a lot of fans
that have some --
some theories about the show
and the finale.
-Okay.
-And I was thinking maybe
I could run through
a few theories.
Again, none of these are true,
maybe -- or maybe they aren't.
You're going to...
-Okay.
-...answer the best you can.
-I love a fan theory.
-Yeah, you don't mind?
-I don't know how much
I'll be able to say,
but [chuckles]
I'll give it a go.
-Okay, one theory --
is there a secret connection
between "Loki" Season 2
and the film "The Marvels"?
[ Audience oohs ]
-I -- Ooh.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, there are connections.
-Oh.
-There are -- There are --
some secret, some not so secret.
-Ooh.
-Um.
-[ Laughs ]
I keep saying "ooh"
to everything.
-Yeah.
-Ooh!
[ Chuckles ] Ooh!
-I don't know what the --
what the fans think
the secret connection is.
-Okay. That's a good --
-I mean...
-That -- That tells me
that there is no connection.
[ Laughter ]
-Well...
My -- My other half
is in "The Marvels,"
and I'm very proud of her.
-Yeah, so --
-So, there you go.
-Yeah.
Congratulations.
-And that's out this weekend.
But in terms of secret
connections --
-Has -- Has Miss Minutes...
-Yeah.
-...been controlling
everything all along?
[ Audience oohs ]
-A good question...
with many answers.
[ Light laughter ]
I mean...we're all watching out
for A.I., right?
A.I. is --
A.I. is the thing that's coming.
And as sort of like
a slightly borderline malevolent
A.I. cartoon clock...
...watch your back.
[ Laughter ]
-Ohh! Okay.
Does "Loki" finale set up
the "Deadpool 3" movie
or the "Avengers: Secret Wars"
movie?
[ Audience oohs ]
-I mean, I know
they're making "Deadpool 3."
And I guess --
-That's not the question, Tom.
[ Laughter ]
-Um.
-Okay.
-I -- I -- It was a --
It's a very good question.
-Okay.
-And I'm thinking
of all the answers
I could give it.
-Yeah. Don't -- I don't want
to get you in trouble.
-Yeah.
-I know that Ryan Reynolds
is in --
he, like, owns a football team
in the UK --
soccer team.
[ Light laughter ]
-No, that's not --
that's not what we asked.
-We -- We talked about soccer,
right?
-No, we talked about football.
-Okay?
-Football --
we it football here.
-Sorry, sorry, football.
-Yeah, no problem.
How about this?
Since Loki knows
how to time slip now,
can he go find someone like...
Tony Stark, aka Iron Man?
[ Audience oohs ]
-This guy.
This is investigative journalism
right here.
[ Laughter ]
Um.
I mean, time slipping
technically gives Loki
some interesting...
[ Drum roll ]
...moves he can make.
[ Chuckles ]
I suppose, yeah, he can move
from past, present, future.
I know that I can time slip.
I don't know that other
characters can time slip.
Speaking for myself,
Loki's died a few times,
come back -- I'm still here.
[ Light laughter ]
So I don't know that --
that death is necessarily --
I mean, death is --
death is up for grabs
as an existential question.
[ Laughter ]
[ Drum roll ]
Um, that's all I can give you.
-All right.
That's all he can say.
Oh, my goodness.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-He's good.
You can't -- can't break him.
Can't break the man.
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
But, Quest -- Quest, can I --
can I get another drum roll,
please,
because this is the first time
we're allowed to show a clip
from an actor's project
on our show for a long time.
-Yeah.
[ Drum roll ]
-We waited.
This is history right here.
And thank you, again,
for coming back.
-Thank you for --
-You know we love you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-Congrats on another
great season of "Loki."
I want to show a clip.
Here's Tom Hiddleston
in Season 2 of "Loki."
Take a look.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on.
They'll have a look at you.
-Where's that?
I need to be back in there.
-No, come on.
-Mobius, I know you're trying
to help me,
but we should be dealing
with the bigger problem here --
He Who Remains.
-I understand,
and we'll get to that.
In order to do to that,
I need a Loki Who Remains.
We need to address the fact
that you keep disappearing.
-What? I don't --
I don't keep disappearing.
We don't have time --
-Loki...
You just disappeared.
-I know.
-And I can't keep looking at it
'cause it's horrible.
-What? I thought you said
it didn't look that bad.
-I was lying.
It -- It's terrible.
Looks like you're being born
or dying
or both at the same time.
It's really --
It's freaking me out.
-It's okay. It's okay.
-It looks really painful.
-It's not that bad.
I can handle it.
-Come on. How does it look?
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Tom Hiddleston, everybody!
"Loki" Season 2
is streaming now on Disney+.
Brie Larson joins us
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause continue ]